in DC rebirth the flash is one of the
best titles that they have going right
now oh my god do the flash is so good
flash rebirth Joshua Williamson I Love
You Man so Wally West meets Wally West
is a one-shot all right this is just a
one-off and it's actually a really
really fun story but not only that this
is really not a story that's just left
you know it doesn't one of those stories
it doesn't do anything because we've
seen this we've seen one-shot stories in
Marvel DC so on and so forth image and
so on we've seen one-shot stories that
don't do anything they're just filler
issues annuals are usually like that
annuals are usually just filler issues
sometimes are part of a bigger story but
more often than not they're just filler
issues with this one shot it's not it
actually sets the stage for something
amazing which I know the flash fans will
love and we will talk about it once we
get to the end but what we do here is we
pick up with Central City on Halloween
and iris West is being met with flowers
now of course she's spending time with
Wally West the new 52 Wally West and
Barry Allen but again something to keep
in mind here is that iris West still
does not know that the pre new 52 Wally
West is here she's not aware of that all
she knows is that there's the new 52
Wally West and there's Barry Allen
that's going to become very important
especially once we get into the latter
part of this comic where we talk about
who it was a stole time from everyone
but in the midst of them hanging out
with Iris trying to figure out who these
flowers are coming from I guess
everybody in the room is suddenly
alerted by the fact that there is a
bridge collapsing and so of course iris
West takes off the new 52 Wally West
takes off as well and so does Barry
Allen although the new 52 Wally West
talks about how he has homework and
Barry Allen talked about how he has a
whole cold case now this is an important
part of the story the reason why I say
that is because Barry Allen has not
revealed his identity as the flash to
the new 52 Wally West he doesn't know
that and that actually creates for some
great storytelling and the reason why is
the new 52 Wally West largely gives us
his inner monologue over the course of
this story and what he says is that for
him Barry Allen or I guess the flash as
he knows him is a hero you know the
flash has had such I guess an important
role in his life with regards to Daniel
West
the reverse-flash for time prior to DC
rebirth neo wally west the new 52 wally
west looks to the flash as an icon a
source somebody in in whose shoes he
wants to follow and so what he does is
of course he goes to the bridge he
fights alongside the flash and to fight
alongside his idol is a huge inspiration
but not only that while they're in the
midst of trying to quell these flames
while they're in the midst of trying to
to save people who are on the bridge
suddenly the pre new 52 Wally West shows
up and this is the coolest thing it's so
cool to see the three new 52 and the new
52 Wally West hanging out and the reason
why is because they could not be
opposite like they're they're polar
opposites the new 52 Wally West isn't
really he's not super serious but he's
got a chip on his shoulder right he's
had some rough experiences in his life
whereas you had the pre new 52 Wally
West who remembers racing alongside
Barry Allen in the pre DC really the pre
new 52 timeline he remembers you know
being the Kid Flash an actual child
racing alongside his idol Barry Allen
and so because of this really it seems
to be kind of a return to familiarity
for the free new 52 Wally West whereas
the new 52 Wally West doesn't know any
of this history because again Barry
Allen and Wally West seem to be the only
two among them who have a bigger picture
who have an understanding of everything
that's going on there are a couple
people here and there who haven't have
an inkling have an idea of course
Batman's doing his investigations but
right now it's really just that the pre
new 52 Wally West and Barry Allen but
while they're there in the midst of
talking with one another you know
suddenly Barry Allen is released it
seems as though he is attacked so to
speak by the Speed Force in the sense
that he has visions and these visions
are actually really interesting of
course we see Gorilla Grodd we have
Captain Cold
we have all these different you know
against the the flashpoint timeline we
have all these different visions you
know coming through the mind of Barry
Allen and the result of this is that he
immediately starts to freak out not only
that a voice seems to take over him and
he starts speaking harshly against the
new 52 Wally West and the pre new 52
Wally West now what he tells the new 52
Wally West
is that Daniel West was actually his
father not his uncle and it was never
revealed to him not only that he starts
to yell at the three new 52 Wally West
about the fact that the three new 52
Wally West is trying to take the place
of Barry Allen now again this really is
maybe some deep-seated emotions maybe
it's some subconscious thoughts that are
rising to the surface but as suddenly it
seems as though this is not actually
Barry Allen talking instead it seems as
though he's being manipulated by eobard
thawne by Professor zoom now this looks
like Joshua Williamson is leading
towards something bigger because at this
moment right now professor zoom as we
know him eobard thawne is currently in
iron Heights he's not free and so
because of this the question is Duty's
is he somehow able to still commune with
the Speed Force so to speak or is this
eobard thawne from a different timeline
or a different reality is the eobard
thawne right now in iron Heights is that
version different from the one before
the new 52 these are a lot of questions
that are being asked right now because
we know the flash point that eobard
thawne was isolated from the future he
was removed he was unchanged so he
wasn't really anchored to the present at
least it didn't seem like he was so
there's a lot of questions that are
being asked right now but at this moment
after these discussions and after a
Barry Allen is freaking out he
ultimately calms down and he comes to
now again for the pre new 52 wally west
he knows Barry Allen well enough to know
that that wasn't him talking but for the
new 52 wally west he doesn't quite have
this mindset yet he's not able to relate
to the flash in that level because he
doesn't even know he's Barry Allen and
so well he is shocked at the fact that
Daniel West is his father and while he
does recognize that this wasn't really
very Allen or I guess the flash speaking
it doesn't change the fact that he's
still hurt by what it was that was said
and so what he does is basically just
take off he just runs out and initially
Barry Allen wants to catch him but the
pre new 52 Wally West says no just let
him run just let him do his thing let
him come to his irritation on his own
terms which was really necessary here
because I think that for the new 52
Wally West we know from his time in the
new 52 line of comics that he's really a
guy that just deals with things on his
own I wouldn't go as far as to say that
he's a true loner but there are a few
times when he just doesn't like dealing
with his problems with the help of other
people instead he's used to dealing with
things on his own and that's one of the
reasons why this story is so good and
why his inclusion in DC rebirth is so
good because
the new 52 Wally West is learning to be
part of a team he's learning that it's
not just him and so what happens is he
immediately runs into his friend chunk
who of course is at a costume party and
chunk says hey man if you having a hard
time there's this guy that you should go
talk to he's a really cool dude he knows
everything about comic books the Golden
Age stuff you should go spend time with
him when we learn this person is or at
least it seems as though it's actually
the pre new 52 Wally West you know this
is his masquerade now as something else
also want to touch base on here is that
the pre new 52 Wally West haven't just
been hanging around in the DC rebirth
Universe right he hasn't just been doing
nothing he's been part of the Titans so
he has his own role to play in DC
rebirth but the fact remains that he
basically sits down and he starts having
a heart-to-heart conversation with the
new 52 Wally West and what he says here
is that that was not the flash of course
you know the pre new 52 Wally West can't
reveal everything about why he
understands you know Barry Allen so well
but the fact remains here that he says
that his history is not that far removed
from the new 52 Wally West in the sense
that the pre new 52 Wally West comes
from a very bad family he comes from
parents that argued all the time that he
was taken from that house he was moved
and he basically lived with iris West
that was when he was introduced to Barry
Allen way back when before crisis on
Infinite Earths scale that was when he
became the kid flash he started racing
alongside Barry Allen as a flash that's
when he basically came into his own and
started becoming a superhero and so the
what heat wave tells Wally is or I guess
what he tells the new 52 Wally West is
that in time he's going to learn that
there's a lot more to the flash than
meets the eye that while the flash can
be intimidating to talk to because of
the fact that he is such a strong hero
because of the fact that he has such a
strong legacy in DC Comics that at the
end of the day he's an excellent teacher
and he's one of the best people to
confide in but in addition to this he
also gives the new the new 52 while he
was a little piece of advice and what he
says is that at some point in the future
the new 52 Wally West is going to
challenge Barry Allen to a race and when
that happens Barry Allen's going to let
him win now when I say Barry Allen of
course I just I mean the flash because
again the new 52 Wally West doesn't know
that Barry Allen is a fly
I'm just saying that cuz I got tired of
saying the flash all the time but the
fact remains you know he's gonna
challenge Barry Allen to a race and when
that happens very Alamo let him win now
having said that I want to see that that
comic I want to read that comic where
Barry Allen races against the new 52
Wally West and I want to see how that
happens but this is also the pre new 52
Wally West telling the new 52 version
Wally West that he doesn't have to deal
with things alone at the time of him
dealing with his problems in isolation
has long since passed because as a
member of the flash family
he always has people that he can go to
now the reason why I love this section
so much is because there's an iconic
image out there of the flash family max
mercury Jay Garrick Wally West Barry
Allen you know so on and so forth and
they're all just running together and to
me that image just symbolizes how
awesome the flash family is it gives you
a feeling of nostalgia especially for
you guys who were reading the flash
before the new 52 it gives you a feeling
of this greatness of what the flash
family is kind of a wholesome feeling in
terms of the fact that they're all
connected through the Speed Force but
they all have so many experiences and
because of that the new 52 Wally West is
now part of that family he's a member of
that family and so there's always
someone to go to now admittedly not
everybody who's part of that family in
the pre new video is there right now
which leads us to the discussion between
Barry Allen and the pre new 52 Wally
West now what we learn is that the pre
new 52 Wally West is the one that's been
sending flowers to iris and the reason
why is that when you know in my video
which you'll find down in the
description on the flash rebirth number
one when Wally West was officially the
pre new 52 Wally West was officially
brought back when he was brought in to
the new 52 continuity by Barry Allen who
remembered his name you know who
expressed his love for him as a member
of his family when that happened Barry
Allen wanted to run Intel iris West what
was going on he wanted to tell her that
the two of them were married before the
new 52 that you know that the pre new 52
Wally West was her nephew but it wasn't
just her out there in isolation by
herself that she had a very important
role to play in the DC landscape but the
pre new 52 Wally West didn't want to
because he didn't want iris to know what
was going on
he didn't think that she was ready more
so than that they wouldn't go to her
with a full story all they would do is
basically go to iris and it would be
Barry Allen saying hey this guy says
that he's your nephew from a reality
that you don't remember and in that
reality you and I were married so let's
go back to doing that and it would it
would like she would know how to react
to it it'd be funny but she wouldn't
know how to react to it then so as a
result it would cause problems not only
that it would also create ripples within
the superhero community because then
other superheroes would come knocking on
their door wanting to know what's going
on and so what they do is they start to
get into this conversation where they
talk about how when the pre-new 32 Wally
West was with the Titans and when they
were going against abracadabra that
abra-cadaver revealed that he was the
reason why no one remembered Wally West
but more so than that someone out there
and they don't know who stole years off
everyone's life and they're trying
they're still trying to figure out who
that person is now from what we've seen
in DC universe rebirth number one that
person seems to be dr. Manhattan but we
still don't know for sure it looks like
is him because of the powers that he
possesses but that question still hasn't
been answered I imagine it'll be a
massive crossover event when we get to
that time which by the way I am hyped to
see a battle between dr. Manhattan and
the Justice League but the ending of
this story is so beast and the reason
why is because Wally West the pre new 52
Wally West asked Barry Allen before they
part ways he said you said you saw
something in the Speed Force
what did you see what you were looking
in the Speed Force and Barry Allen says
he saw something that gave people hope
and what we're shown is the helmet of
Jay Garrick oh my god I'm sorry if I'm
so excited people like I'm so hyped for
this Jay Garrick we might be seeing Jay
Garrick return to the new 52 the DCP
earth landscape which we need to see
because he's been gone for so long but
um but that's basically it I mean it
seems as though this one shot is
designed for the purpose of giving the
new 52 wally west up a home to show him
that he has a family outside of iris
west but it also seems to be like
teasing the return of Jay Garrick which
I'm super happy about but we happen he
said if you guys are new here to a
college explain feel free to hit the sub
button become part of the robb
if you guys are if you guys enjoyed this
video drop a like because I love this
this little this little comic and I
leave a comment down below let me know
are you guys hyped about the possible
return of Jay Garrick man I'd be so
hyped to see that happen and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]